Speaker 1: We've been covering what's going on
in the Georgia Senate race. This is the race in
which former football player Herschel Walker is
the Republican nominee. He became the Republican
nominee without even participating in a debate.
And now the question is, will Herschel Walker
debate? Raphael Warnock? Raphael Warnock, as
the incumbent senator, a Democrat in Georgia.
The backstory on Herschel Walker that has been
notable is that he is almost unable to speak
and almost unable to express himself and to give
us his opinion on any issue. He's asked questions
and he puts together words, salads of no meaning
whatsoever. And there are questions as to whether
he is even going to debate. Raphael Warnock.
Recently, Herschel Walker has started to claim
that he has accepted a debate, and the language,
to the extent that we can decipher it, is bizarre.
It's about a debate in Raphael Warnock's backyard.
It's not going to be for the press, but it's going
to be for the fans. And it's extraordinarily
weird. And over the last week, we have confirmed
that Herschel Walker still can't speak and
probably won't debate. Here is one appearance over
the weekend by Herschel Walker on Fox Business.
And he I gather he's talking about whether he
will debate, but what he says is completely
unintelligible. See if you can understand it.
Speaker 2: Are you going to debate him?
Speaker 5: Well, I've called him on two debates.
Speaker 1: And called him on two debates.
What does that mean? It means nothing.
Speaker 5: On two debates, he turned me down
on both of them because I said what I want
to do is see a fair and accurate debate.
Speaker 1: I have seen no evidence that
Raphael Warnock has turned down two debates.
Speaker 5: With 42 people, not about some press,
not about some party. But the people get
a chance to see the differences between
my opponent and myself with my opponent.
Believe in raising taxes during a recession.
My opponent believe being soft on crime. He
voted with Joe Biden, the elected officials. That
is soft on crime. My opponent believes that he
voted. They put me in. And remember, the question.
Speaker 1: Was, are you going to debate.
Speaker 5: In sports where I do not think
men should be in women's sports. So it has
a big difference. In contrast, I think he's
afraid to say in front of his Georgia voters
and stand up for the record that he's voted on.
Speaker 1: That is meaningless. Now, if there
is such a debate, I will cover it. That would
be an extraordinary debate to cover. But I am not
getting the sense that Herschel Walker actually
plans to debate. How could he debate if he can't
even answer the question? Are you going to debate?
It doesn't make any sense. And, you know,
he speaks with this very scrambled syntax
and it's almost like trying to decipher a
verbal Morse code to listen to Herschel Walker.
But again, I don't know why it was ever claimed
that he agreed to a debate, because the more I
listen to him, it sounds like he's maybe
saying there's going to be a town hall. I
don't really know. Here's another clip of Herschel
Walker. I hesitate to use the word explaining,
but he's talking, I guess, about this debate.
Speaker 5: I don't know why not. Next, our media
group offered to host a debate for us in Savannah.
Speaker 1: Now, by the way, these are the new
videos that Walker's doing very clearly,
reading off of some kind of notes.
Even reading off of the notes. I still
don't know what the hell he's talking about.
Speaker 5: October the 14th, in
front of the people. Don't be scared.
I know you rejected previous offers.
Speaker 1: I made no evidence of that.
Speaker 5: But please consider this one.
This debate is more than fair to you,
and it's for the people is in your own backyard,
savannah. Right. You have hometown advantage
is being hosted by a respected third party media
group with multiple outlets in Georgia. It will be
aired statewide on broadcast television.
Speaker 1: By the way, Nexstar is like
this right wing media company. I'm sure
they would host the debate. But again,
nobody knows what Walker is
talking about in primetime.
Speaker 5: So everybody will get a chance to
watch. It is a primetime showdown in Savannah.
You know what I mean? Come on,
Rafael. Let's do this for Georgia.
October the 14th. I'll be there with you.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: It's sort of sounds like what
Walker wants to do is some kind of town hall.
It's not even clear what he's talking about,
to be perfectly frank. But I have to tell you,
when Trumpists are your supporters,
there's no downside to Walker. Just saying,
I want a debate, and Raphael Warnock won't do it.
And of course, it'll be a made up lie. Warnock
might be perfectly willing to debate. In fact,
I believe he is. But what Walker should do
if I were listen, if I were his advisers,
I would not want him to debate. I mean, he can't
speak, so how can you debate? I would advise him.
Start claiming that Warnock won't debate. You make
it up. It'll be a lie. I think that actually is
his best strategy. And a lot of his followers
will believe it. Let me know your thoughts and
we'll have these clips on her Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.